hello there the summer is here and
fortnite's update has landed which has a
whole month of content to be found as
well as enjoying the sun i've also taken
a closer look at the story missions
we've been completing to discover some
interesting finds i'm adamaru this is
week seven of season three
summer time always brings something to
the island from giant rappers trampling
the world two giant rubber ducks
floating upstream this year no sweat
insurance is back in fortnight and they
have brought back the floats seen in
chapter 2. over the last week a stage
and what looks to be a skate park have
slowly started construction it's no
secret that epic have been displaying a
lot of skateboards recently which led us
all to hope and expect skateboarding to
be one of the new ways to get around
over the summer in a coming update the
stage float may look lackluster right
now but cast your mind back remember
when travis turned up and we quickly
realized that little stage was not
needed the concert was way way bigger so
if we get another concert this year
expect the unexpected and also expect it
to be part of the overarching storyline
too just like when ariana arrived and
the cube queen read our minds to find
the zero point that was a bit trippy
[Music]
the next major update this week is found
at sleepy sounds the sapling we saw
growing one week ago finally sprouted
and became four pois neo tilted coral
castle colossal coliseum and tilted town
all thanks to those reality routes which
are spreading fast some may say
worryingly fast sleepy shrubs is
surprisingly only the northernmost part
of the location and i think i know why
the bromance here's one of the spots i
didn't show you last week the fab 4 can
be found giving us an impromptu
performance on a rooftop in homage to
the beatles or if you're not that old a
homage to the simpsons which was a
homage to the beatles anyway if you're
lucky the fab four will give you your
own personal performance from a rooftop
the story of the season is slowly
building and we are just getting to a
good point and suddenly it was paused
for a month to make way for the summer
shenanigans a few weeks ago the
scientist admitted something that the
freeing of the zero point the thing
we've worked for years to get may have
been a mistake since then we've been
working with the scientists and his ai
assistant called amy the reality tree
seems like a great place to relax but we
could have already seen our next enemy
the watcher the bloom observer very
ominous the scientist believes the zero
point is trying to speak to us giving
off an energy shock wave which is slowly
rising up the richter scale he surmises
that the zero point is deliberately
bringing us different relics this season
to help us prepare for battle so far
we've found a sith holocron no less
which is like a key of information which
darth vader would kill for then we also
recovered a relic from the indiana jones
movies something which transcends the
holder towards godliness
there it is again another zero point
energy shock wave magnitude 7.2 the zero
point has got to be bringing these
relics here because it wants us to have
them right and if the leaks are right
we'll see a dragon ball crossover soon
which relic could that storyline bring
in other mythical relics the reality
bloom has given us were all themed
around the four previous pois we've
mentioned neo-tilted coral castle tilted
towers and colossal coliseum yet there
was one other which appeared for a
moment on our search for a relic we
found this recognize it a frozen shield
with the mark of the ice king upon it
the man who froze the island back in
chapter one and then completely vanished
and we never heard from again what makes
this more alluring is thanks to the
marvel comic book series the zero war in
issue two has brought back the hybrids
another forgotten skin and we first saw
them in egg form frozen in the ice
king's home as the temperature slowly
rose
these two events must be linked somehow
the zero point is bringing us god-like
relics and we already know there are
gods in fortnite law already could they
be returning the zero point seems to be
on our side and wants us to be ready the
problem now though is we have to wait a
whole month for the storyline to
continue as right now epic games and
their staff are on their annual summer
jollies it's vacation time for them and
we didn't even get to talk about the new
faction the peace syndicate they've
rocked up onto the island this season
and set up shop in the restaurant on the
water's edge the one with midas's design
inside this could be huge we just have
to wait four weeks
of course there are other stories to
keep us occupied in the meantime like
the life of the rock fam these have been
around for a long time long enough to
see the original ice king and the
prisoner do battle and after being lost
for a number of years they finally
re-emerged in the desert and after
crawling free made a new farmstead by
the beach and for seven weeks they
relaxed completely vibing the dad has
now drank his own body weight in slurp
juice which his dog would fetch him
regularly but check out the dog now he's
completely done he's collapsed from the
heat of being worked like a dog sharon
stone continues to sunbathe next to her
husband and she's reading non-stop her
two favorite books seem to be cipher's
playbook and now she has gone back to
the book taken from midas's library we
are still waiting to know if that is
important but that's the second
reference to midas today and then we
also have kid rock i have no idea what
he's doing this week he's collected
washed up trash and he's using them like
pokemon cards i really don't know if
epic wants us to think about water
pollution or this kid has some sort of
fetish for trash but he's doing this
right now and he guesses what it is oh
and this is a good one a few people have
said when visiting this spot the sand
castle the lad is building can sometimes
look like this the tilted towers clock
tower just to make sure i'm not getting
trolled if you're on switch could you
check this spot for me please is the kid
building a sand version of tilted towers
and speaking of tilted towers it's
finally time no sweat insurance have
taken back their building and are ready
to work once again led by a new
character the underwriter the no sweat
company are building the summer event
pois on the water right now but they
will also give us the ability to vote
for the tilted rebuild user-created
buildings will be erected after we pay
for it of course capitalism is here in
fortnight no sweat insurance is all
about taking our gold but looking at the
designs it seems to be worth it
[Music]
a really weird change today sees the
cactuses we looked at last season you
know the ones with the cones on their
heads over time and now a cactus has
grown higher than the rest and sports
this gear i have no idea what i'm
looking at but i like it and finally
truckasaurus has an update the myth now
has an arm and a sword attached or is
that a walking stick soon this slowest
update since hot watch will be finished
maybe it is going to be optimus prime we
shall see the next time we meet for an
update video like this condo canyon will
be taken over by the roots of the
reality tree right now it's already
ripping apart the poi demolishing
vehicles as it goes and not even the
daily bugle can avoid it the roots will
reach here and cause reality surges this
will hopefully line up with the comic
book series as spider-man from that
universe is trying to get that poi back
home and i'm really sorry by the way
that i haven't finished the issue 2
breakdown i'll have it ready for this
weekend you have my word in fact i'll go
do that now thanks for your time here's
a mega bunch of legends who used my code
in the store thank you so much for
sticking with me guys i really
appreciate it i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you